hello everyone and welcome to what is
not only one of the greatest games but
also one of the greatest moves that was
ever played it was played by Frank
Marshall in his game against Stefan
Levitsky in 1912 where after Rook
captures on H3 you cannot recapture
because of Knight to F3 check with the
monster Fork here so Rook the C5 was
played attacking Marshall's Queen but
here Marshall just played Queen to G3
and that there you have it that's the
American Beauty that's the move that
supposedly triggered the shower of gold
coins from the audience uh if you
capture the queen then Knight the E2 is
just made in one if you capture with the
F Pawn then again Knight stage to check
King H1 Rook captures and F1 is a forced
Checkmate and uh of course if you
capture with the queen then you're just
gonna be down a piece because after this
check again forking the queen and king
captures you are now down a full night
because if the Knight is captured Rook
captures on F1 is again Checkmate so
there you have it that's the American
Beauty hope you enjoyed it